привіт ну що давайте дамо відповідь нашому
Володимиру Олександровичу
він розповіла про успіхи останнього часу
але природно як завжди по-своєму і
так що ж ми маємо
повернули кораблі він закликає нас
радіти мовчить про морський трибунал
рішенням якого росію зобов'язали повернути
і кораблі і моряків і чиє рішення качок
на кажучи
Росії виконує те, що вона над ним
знущається з нас усіма там зіграють
навіть знімаю унітази
ну про це він якось промовчав grid все
поверне росія так упевнено якщо так
легко ти можеш повернути поверни нам крим
унітазами нехай путін піддаються а ось
крим би не завадило повернути каже про
тому що ось бачите прийняли ми бюджет і
дуже швидко буквально в лічених там
пару днів виявляється бюджет хороший це
той що прийнятий за пару днів я думав
що добрий бюджет той який
нормально і дає людям можливості для
життя де зарплати вчителів яку ти
обіцяв учень вова двійка тобі по
математиці 4 тисячі доларів за були ти
ж людям взагалі нічого не підняв
інфляція плюс 2 відсотки для вчителів
інфляція плюс три відсотки для
військовослужбовців заморожена мінімальна
пенсія як входить у рік 1638 р.
пенсія як і до 1 липня 1638 р.
а з 1 липня буде 1712 на 74 гривні
більше
але не вистачить на квитковий 95 квартал
правда тепер це шоу безкоштовно і для
всієї країни
тому такий бюджет жахливий
купив бюджет злиднів обіцяв кінець епохи
бідності, а насправді отримуємо епоху
злиднів
завдяки тобі володіючи і ось така
історія яку ми бачимо з бюджетом, а ти
розповідаєш дивіться як класно що
ми його швидко прийняли виявляється там
очистили себе трьох депутатів тільки
хотів нагадати тобі щоб чак чи
приймаючи кораблі
ти сказав що депутат ґвалтівник покладе
мандат
що ти поговориш і буде на столі
мандата шанс грішать і трапилися фракції
радійте, а чому все нормально у
бороди синя борода багатогрішна
богдан яременко на ньому ти мовчиш а
всієї корупції яка у твій фракції
процвітають мовчиш типу все так не треба
виключили
2 1 ґвалтівника виключили які
залишається народним депутатом і буде
приймати закони за якими жити сорока
мільйонній країні та ще двох людей
які не хочуть просто голосувати так
як голосують твоя моно б'ють це
звичайно велике досягнення і кажеш ми
а слуги народу
ну ми бачимо чиї послуги
хто носить туди по 5 тисяч доларів
конвертер зарплати а це мільйон двісті
на місяць на секунду ось тих ви
послуги і ми це все чудово розуміємо та
бачимо за результатами норманська зустріч
говориш радіємо дотиснули
дотиснули ну я не знав що виявляється
зустрічі з путіним та велика подія для
і результат який буде подивимося але
поки що зустрітись і щоб тримати
довелося погодитися на формулу, що він
майора насправді формулу путіна
довелося
йти на всі побажання путіна говориш
це перемога подивимося 9 грудня у парижі
загалом якщо пройтися по всіх цих мега
досягненням в яких ти озвучив те
звичайно таке продовжує висіти
корупційне виправлення завдяки якій
державний бюджет матеріал
мільярди гривень на ринку тютюнових
виробів продовжує очолювати комітет
з міжнародних справ богдан яременко
з міжнародних зносин ми просто
носіння мужик впізнаємо його
і багато чого іншого в загальному
непереконливий
володіючи підсумком і не вийде тебе просто
так от розповідати все що тобі
подобається, а будемо ми говорити правду
ну і остання ти сказав томи ринку
землі радіємо говориш чому радіємо
володіючи тому що продамо землю
олігархам ти говориш іноземних там не
буде ну та в принципі а хто ігор валерій
ніж іноземної олігарха або наш не h3
паспорти 3 володіючи 3
тому таке справді щастя
щоб продати швидше за безцінь
українську землю кільком олігархам
це дійсно досягнення та перемоги
тільки таких перемог мільйони людей
виходять
загалом володіючи ось вони такі реальні
результати боротимемося ми з тобою
тому що володіючи
обманює що людей та країн побачиш
пропасти ось так